[Music]
okay so I know I'm late to the party on
this but I finally got around to
watching killing Eve after my wife
begged me and begged me to put down the
Marvel movies and pick up something else
naturally my interest was piqued quite
heavily when I saw the show picking up
several awards at the Golden Globes and
it's pretty clear that this has a lot to
impart from it throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about killing [ __ ] and
its ending there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the show or its
conclusion and then I highly recommend
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to killing he've tells the tale of
a deadly game of cat and mouse that
centers around two women the titular
character Eve and her target villanelle
deciding which one is the cat and which
one is the mouse becomes a little hard
to distinguish as each episode including
the finale god I'm tired
turns the tables regularly Eve begins
the series as a desk-bound mi6 officer
who makes it her mission to track down
the extremely talented assassin and
villanelle as the series progresses the
two characters become obsessed with one
another and this culminates in an almost
fatal showdown in the final episode
after villanelle turns on her mentor
Constantine he is forced to go to e for
help she however counteracts this and
shoots Constantine in a deadly standoff
that allows her to escape however Eve
tracks down the killer to her Parisian
apartment and arrives before she reaches
it this is important for Eve as she was
pretty heavily violated throughout the
show with villanelle often outsmarting
her at every opportunity but Eve finally
has the upper hand and uses this to her
advantage Eve takes pleasure in this
scenario and completely upend
villanelles apartment before she returns
when Belen elders return she seems
completely nonchalant to the entire
ordeal and even taunts Eve slightly
remarking that though she lost her best
friend job and husband she at least got
some nice clothes out of it it's at this
point when Eve has the upper hand and is
about to shoot Miller now that she
admits she in fact has an obsession with
the woman
after pretty much making her the center
of her entire life mirroring this of
belem l2 confirms that she is as equally
obsessed in her feelings towards Eve the
two slept down on the bed together and
we get very much a yin and yang
situation where it's very clear that
they pretty much require one another to
exist villanelle even states that she's
never done anything like this before
when asked if she's going to kill Eve
and it becomes apparent that the two are
opposites of the same coin
providing balance to each other's lives
everything seems like it's going to be
the start of a beautiful new
relationship of cops and robbers until
there's a big twist it's at this moment
that Eve stabs fuller now in the back
almost literally and pulls out a
retractable knife wounding villanelle
with what is almost a fatal blow it's
clear that this was a panic response as
Eve seems frightened by her actions
villanelle asks Eve to leave the knife
but she hastily pulls it out and tries
to help bill and out shoots at her Andy
flees to the kitchen and discovering
that villanelle has disappeared on her
return so what happens next
well Eve is pretty much lost everything
she had after being fired from mi6
however her cunningness to track Eve
down in Paris might prove her saving
grace the agent is clearly adept at her
job so there's no reason that her
dismissal can't be undone
in terms of villanelles wound I think we
all know that she's got more lives than
a cat and this won't be the end of her
the assassin will no doubt be well
equipped and trained to deal with things
like this and due to her ability to
disguise herself she will more than
likely be able to obtain treatment from
a hospital or medical professional she
will likely be after Eve due to the
betrayal and this could be a big factor
in season two also viewers should expect
a return from Constantine though he was
apparently shot in season one we never
actually saw the character die so it
seems unlikely that this would be the
end of him Caroline the Eve's former
boss could have easily made it appear
that he is dead and he could be working
with the British government now
obviously we will all find out when
season two is released and I can't wait
to see how the saga unfolds so what are
your thoughts on the ending of killing
Eve and did you enjoy the series comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of Netflix is
you which will be linked at the end this
is a channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing
like you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you